[Music]
all right mike
thanks to a late three-pointer by lebron
james
deep three-pointer his lakers beat steph
curry in the warriors last night in nba
playoff play in game mike
could a good drama kind of sets up our
draft for the day
you know this new play and things kind
of cool with the nba but we got to see
steph
versus lebron round one pretty good
lakers win now they're the seventh seed
and now the warriors got to play
uh i believe the grizzlies who beat the
spurs so
kind of a cool thing there but that
inspired our draft the playoff duels we
want to see in 2021.
all right go ahead you have the honors i
got the honors okay cool
all right um like we can't pick the
super bowl that's what i wanted to ask
first right or like why not
it's the post season all right fine
bucks versus pats that's what i want to
see i mean yes that's what i want to see
the brand new uh new england team
the team that has a chance to be like
like the bucks really to be like man
look at all this talent we got here we
go we're
i mean bill belichick and get to be like
a repeat of the week season
or week four match up who knows where
that goes that would add to like some of
the
theatrics of a super bowl matchup can
brady win
eight because belichick has eight
already so now they could be tied and we
can have this debate forever
you know and everything so that that to
me would be really cool
uh especially if cam newton's the
quarterback too uh that that's the one
that jumps out
see that's where i have an issue with
your selection and i don't want to spend
a whole lot of time
you know criticizing it but it's brady
versus who
what's the duel there brady versus the
entire team belichick
how about that that's kind of like an
important one all right so you know
shut your snarky combat up and make your
own i'm just helping you
flesh out your selection and make it you
know sensible brady versus belichick
yes roger's in my homes rogers in my
homes i don't care where rogers is
denver las vegas san francisco green bay
anywhere
yeah rogers and mahomes we've been
deprived of that matchup yeah we're
supposed to get it week nine if he stays
with the packers maybe we'll get it
twice if he ends up with the broncos or
with the raiders
but i want rogers in my homes in the
postseason we thought maybe we'd get it
last year in the super bowl we got brady
mahomes instead
yeah i'll settle for that yeah we want
to see rogers in mahomes in
in a in a single elimination setting
yeah that would be i mean that would be
ideal that would be
amazing it really would be uh and and
you know hopefully we get to see it in
the regular season
and the super bowl i'll be down for that
too you know there's something there
about when it happens in the regular
season too i feel like it adds a little
more stress
to the super bowl game too uh that i
like
like in that aspect all right i'm gonna
go like a little coaches thing here
a little bit i'd like to see rams 49ers
in an nfc championship game
specifically macvaver shanahan that's
what i want to see
just because they're friends they're in
the same division
it'd be the third game right they of
course work together
i think there's a legit friend friendly
rivalry there
of always watching each other you know i
guess yes it's a little personal to me
because i know those guys and i like
them but i still also think if i didn't
know them
these are the two young whipper snappers
in football
the two kid geniuses and them to go at
it you know and be in division rivals
and everything like that that would be
one that would
get my blood boiling a little bit you
know i
i like that one and it's hard for me to
ignore
the obvious ones and it is hard i know
i i mean mahomes would be involved in
all these there are so many guys you
want to see
against mahomes yeah you know i i'll go
baker mayfield in my homes we saw it
last year my homes got injured but they
have that rivalry that dates back to
college they had the 66
59 game for crying out loud at oklahoma
and texas tech mayfield was with the
sooners and
and uh mahomes with the red raiders the
browns gave them everything they can
handle they start the season this year
week one
browns at chiefs maybe we see browns at
chiefs again
in the postseason but mayfield in
mahomes with both guys healthy both guys
playing the whole game i'd like to see
that i
agreed i listen i i'm with you it's hard
to avoid mahomes versus anybody
it really is i mean i'm i'm sitting here
going i'm doing the same thing you are
going wait
i don't want to pick him again because
really realistically
i'd want to see mahomes versus josh
allen again
i mean honestly because i just feel like
the bill i i'd like to see the budding
of a rivalry
i'm going to pick it i'm going to pick
it i don't care josh allen versus holmes
yeah
i think the two most talented
big play quarterbacks we have in the
game right now are these two guys and i
wouldn't mind to see
the start of a manning brady rivalry
here in the afc between these two guys
last week last year could be the jump
off yeah mahomes has got them 1-0
and here we go and how does this go i
mean to me that would be a blast and
that's what's cool about the afc
like holy crapola that they have
quarterbacks in the afc
every team has got a franchise superstar
it seems like
so there's unlimited great matchups when
you kind of play around with it
in that conference i'm going to go with
one that is extremely unrealistic
there's others i've
toyed with you know justin herbert
versus patrick mahomes would be great
because they played twice during the
regular season anyway and that's a
rivalry that could develop over time
russell wilson and aaron rodgers a
couple of guys who want help
of the teams they're currently with how
about two guys who got out of their
current teams this year even though one
did so reluctantly jared goff and
matthew stafford
getting together i got you they play in
the regular season right that would that
would be a compelling playoff game that
otherwise you look at ram's lines in the
playoffs and you just kind of
you know kind of crinkle your nose and
say oh well it's on tv i guess i'll
watch it no no
stafford and golf if somehow the lions
can get there that would be worth
spending the time watching
every second of it would yeah it's that
personal aspect we talk about
i mean just it makes it fun when it gets
personal because you know there's some
real
like we want to stick to this guy i
don't want to lose to him any of that
that's
that's where i i like that pick a lot i
wrote it down too
just for that that exact reason the
other one i thought about just to add to
the conversation a little bit is like
flores versus belichick
you know that's another one man i mean
you afc championship game if those two
had a deal
duel it out with their history they're
both tough sobs everything like that
that'd be a cool one uh i'd i i'd also
sign up for rogers
rogers brady in the nfc championship
game part two without a doubt too
right now absolutely hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports